we are used to heat here in southern
nevada of course but
long-term heat waves with these kind of
record temperatures
that's unusual and it's also dangerous
bianca holman spoke with the national
weather service with some insight
and some tips to try and stay cool
bianca
yeah so staying out of the sun and
staying hydrated is something we're used
to
living here in las vegas and in southern
nevada but experiencing these hot
temperatures for
several days well that's something we're
not used to we were able to check in
with the national weather service and
they say
that there's nothing typical about our
temperatures this week
there are records that may be broken
with temperatures running 10 to 15
degrees above normal
in 2013 a heat wave in southern nevada
had 30 fatalities and more than 350 heat
related injuries
this heat is serious and officials want
everyone to stay safe through this
extended heat wave
it's actually very unusual and one of
the questions we get a lot is
why do we worry about the heat it's the
summer in the desert that's true it does
get warmer at this time but not to this
fast and doesn't last this long
and we're talking about record
temperatures being broken not just in
one site we're talking about
over 40 different locations that might
be seeing record-breaking temperatures
and not for one day
possibly five six or even seven days so
this is
quite a bit uncommon this is not typical
desert southwest heat
and so you might think hitting the lake
will cool you off but that could be
dangerous as well
the water may be cooler but the land
around the lake is hotter than in the
city and you can easily experience
hypothermia heat streak
heat stroke or heat exhaustion and of
course another reminder when it comes to
our vehicles
they say put a something very important
maybe like your purse or your wallet in
the back seat so that you don't forget
your child
or your pet heat related deaths are very
very serious
and they can happen in a matter of
minutes bianca holman 8 news now